[Music]  hey guys everyone my subscribers my  viewers everyone um i was just sitting  down and i was thinking about how many  videos i've already done and i was  trying to think of something to kind of  expand my channel get more viewers etc  and i came up with that i would start  like a tech talk now obviously this is  youtube so you can't talk with your  viewers obviously if you can message  them you can comment on the video and i  can respond obviously  but what i was thinking was i would just  go through like the tech news of the day  and i would just do videos on it just  like talk about the racing stuff you  might have watched my video probably in  the related videos or uh the more from  marcus brownlee stuff  um  about windows 7 and that was what i was  thinking i was going to do more stuff  like that as well as